justement on va revoir la vidéo de denis
brogniart qui c'était la première
réaction de libraire vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en avez pensé par
action de devenir garde à tous je suis
rentré aujourd'hui à paris je voulais
simplement vous dire quelques mots
d'abord j'ai une pensée pour tous les
aventuriers de cette saison qui a été
arrêté je voulais vous dire aussi que
dès que j'ai été prévenu de la situation
au petit matin du cinquième jour j'ai
très vite compris que je ne pourrais pas
continuer à présenter cette saison
la décision de la production de
suspendre l'émission a été partagé par
tous des équipes techniques et tf1 qui
comme moi ont été marqués par cet
événement un grand merci du fond du
coeur à tous ceux nombreux qui m'ont
envoyé des messages chaleureux et puis
je peux vous l'annoncer koh lanta
reviendra bientôt sur tf1 alors
justement denis brogniart sachez qu'il
était lui et ne voulait pas reprendre le
tournage synapauc jeune denis brogniart
a refusé de reprendre le tournage ne
voulait pas du tout reprendre cette
saison de koh lanta
donc il a vraiment poussé pour que la
production arrête cette saison il
voulait pas continuer et et moi j'arrête
d'animer dans ces conditions oui mathieu
sauf que dieu c'est toute l'affection
que j'ai pour ce cet animateur qui à mon
sens est dans le top 3 des garçons des
plus gentils la télévision je pense
sincèrement mais comment at il pu
accepter de lire ce texte évidemment
écrit par tf1 et on sent qu'il y quelque
chose et c'est aussi parce que encore
une fois du conditionnel mais ce qu'il
est en train de dire en gros c'est ya
peut-être eu une tentative de viol mais
chômeuse gones le tournage repart samara
doniol d'agression sexuelle d'agression
sexuelle par lyon mais chômeuse gones ça
va revenir
c'est hallucinant de dire ça c'est entre
vos rêves le problème koh lanta revient
mais moi je trouve ça hallucinant que
c'est extrêmement maladroit graduent
parler du problème dire que c'est grave
se poser des questions et faute poser
les vraies questions encore une fois
entre l'agression la dernière fois à
cette fois ci est la dernière fois un
mort je pense qu'il faudrait maintenant
commencer à dire pardon je termine juste
commencé à dire il s'est passé quelque
chose de grave on va en parler c'est de
comprendre et on verra derrière si ça
revient
là il a l'air de minimiser comme s'il ne
s'était rien passé s'il s'est passé
quelque chose que de 10 g 20 il est il
est passé de nous comprendre
rené d'extrêmement départ d'isabelle ne
lancez pas un départ il faisait une
déclaration et en tant qu une
déclaration il peut pas tout mettre
dedans
la seule chose qu à mon avis on peut lui
reprocher c'est d'avoir eu un petit ton
léger un petit ton comme si présenter
une émission de normal
le pôle aval et la grèce c'est la phrase
de conclusion qui est dommage c'est à
dire que tout le tout le talent bien sûr
est formidable effectivement il dit
qu'il ya un souci effectivement indiqué
qu'il est extrêmement embêté par ce qui
se passe il aurait dû s'arrêter là oui
pour une plaie nord-est pour la suite du
programme
on s'en fiche pour lui il ya un temps
pour tout assurer d'abord une première
vidéo et éventuellement d'en rire sûr
quand on en sait un peu plus il peut
faire une deuxième vidéo pour dire mais
c'est la côte et les amoureux de deux
accords à continuer la pression